FELIPE HOFFA:
Hello, data heroes.
I have a new data
challenge for you.
I'm Felipe Hoffa, a Google
Cloud developer advocate.
And I'm here to tell you
about our BigQuery Challenge,
where every week, you can enter
to win $500 in Cloud Credits.
And all you need to know
is BigQuery and SQL.
You know that BigQuery
has many public data
sets ready for your
analysis and you don't even
need a credit card to get
a free account with one
terabyte of free queries every
month, so let's have some fun.
To participate in the
challenge, just go every week
to goo.gle/bqchallenge
and find two SQL queries.
Run these two
queries in BigQuery
and post the answers in
the participation form.
Every week, we'll
randomly choose
between the correct
entries, and you
might be the winner of
the $500 in Cloud Credits.
So go to goo.gle/bqchallenge
and run the two queries you will
find there.
And make sure to submit your
answers using the participation
form.
Stay curious and join
the BigQuery Challenge.